[موسيقى]
ولد كريستيانو رونالدو دو سانتوس افيرو في
الخامس من فبراير عام
1985 وهو الاصغر بين اخوته الاربعه كانت
والدته تعمل طهيه وكان والده بستانيا
المدينه
عاشت عائلته في مادارا التي اصبحت الان
وجهه سياحيه ذات شعبيه كبيره وهي جزيره
صغيره قباله الساحل البرتغالي لكن في
العام
1985 كانت مدار تعيش في فقر متقع ويسكنها
مجتمع صغير جدا ذكر رونالدو ان عائلته
عاشت حياه متواضعه خاليه من البذخ والرخاء
بكل تاكيد ولد كريستيانو في عائله كبيره
جدا في جزيره ماديرا وكانت عائلته تعيش في
فنشال لا اعتقد انه يمكن القول انما ديرا
تقع في منتصف المحيط الاطلسي فهذا غير
صحيح لكنها بعيده جدا عن بر البرتغال
الرئيسي فذلك لا يشبه الترعرع في لشبونه
او بورتو او احدى المدن بل الحياه فيها
مختلفه جدا عن البر البرتغالي الرئيسي فهو
مجتمع صغير جدا وكان رونالدو يلعب كره
القدم هناك مع عائلته واصدقائه في شوارع
مادارا وانخرط مع النادي المحلي كان والده
يعمل مدير معدات بدوام جزئيا لدى النادي
المحلي لذا ولد في عائله لها موطئ قدم في
اللعبه اذا تربى على يد اب عاشق لكره
القدم وهو امر شديد الاهميه بالطبع
بالنسبه الى كريستيانو الصغير حين بدا
يشحذ مهاراته في شوارع فونشال كان في نادي
الشباب المحلي يكتسب مهاراته الكرويه وكان
يشعر كانه على بعد ملايين الكيلومترات عن
اضواء الانديه الاوروبيه الساطعه التي
يطمح لان يلعب معها
في سن الثامنه انضم رونالدو الى فريق
الشباب الاول له وهو فريق اندورينا حيث
كان والده يعمل مدير معدات بدوام جزئي
اصبحت كره القدم الانهاوسا بالنسبه اليه
وكان يمارسها في الشوارع والملعب على
السواء في سن العاشره انتقل الى واحد من
اكبر النوادي في ماديرا وهو ناديناسيونال
لكن اثناء اللعب مع النادي اكتشفه مكتشف
مواهب كره قدم وفي سن 12 تم اختياره ليقدم
تجربه اداء للانضمام الى الفريق البرتغالي
سبورتنج
اعتقد ان موهبه رونالدو الفذه كانت واضحه
منذ سن مبكره كانت واضحه لعائلته وزملائه
في الفريق وجميع من حوله وعلى الرغم من ان
ماديرا بعيده جدا عن بر البرتغال الرئيسي
الا ان النوادي الكبيره في بر البرتغال
الرئيسي كانت على درايه بما يحصل وكانوا
متحمسين للذهاب والاستعلام عن شخص يتسبب
بكل هذه الضجه حتى لو كان في جزيره ماديرا
الواقعه في عرض المحيط الاطلسي وعندما كان
رونالدو في سن 12 دعاه فريق سبورتنج الى
لشبونه هل يمكنكم تخيل حجم الانتقال من
جزيره مادارا الصغيره جدا والتي تعد مجرد
بركه صغيره جدا ليجد فجاه انه اخذ الى
سبورتنج الذي لديه اكاديميه خاصه به
بالقرب من لشبونه